ask a question that the Quran says that
Allah has put love and mercy between the
hearts of men and women what he's
quoting is the verse of the Quran of Sur
Room chapter number 30 verse number 21
where Allah says that Allah has put love
and mercy between the hearts of men and
women but many people think love means
Haram Taboo in Islam see love is not
Taboo in Islam but done according to
Quran is
right love what they have lbw in the
college is the love before wedding not
in
cricket love before wedding that you go
to a movie theater alone and want to
check how with the girlfriend that's all
Haram but love between man and woman
done in the right way is
good therefore belov Prophet Sall was
said that if you have sex with the wife
it's charity s said that having sex with
the wife charity I didn't
understand so the prophet said that
because you're not doing anything Haram
you AR doing Z you're doing Halal that
is Charity so imagine so now coming back
to your question that how did the
prophet